welcome back John sensor demands for a
full ceasefire are now growing across
the world one of my next guest Jen Yuga
has been among the loudest voices
calling for one his name was written on
an Israeli bomb to be dropped on Gaza
along with that of Andrew Tate Muhammad
hijab all previous po Palestinian guests
on this show well I'm joined Now by
Democratic presidential candid Jen you
got masab Hassan yusf the son of the
Hamas co-founder shik Hassan yusf masab
is opposed of Terror groups as defecting
in the 90s and the former Chelsea at
Israel manager abam Grant joins me live
in the studio I'm great to see you and
I'll come to you in just a moment uh Jen
I want to start with you because pretty
extraordinary to see your name scrolled
on a IDF bomb just first of all what was
your response to
that yeah uh it's of course
disheartening to see it it's sick uh
they're going to drop those bombs on
Palestinian civilians they're probably
going to murder babies and and
grandmothers with those bombs that's why
if I'm president I won't send Israel a
single dollar not only the $4 billion
they're considering now but I would end
all funding to Israel as they have
massacred civilian after civilian 19,000
dead 9,000 children butchered I do not
want a single American Tax dollar going
to help Israel commit war crimes and if
they think they're going to intimidate
me by putting my name on on their bombs
they've got another thought coming to
them we're at a state in this war where
Hamas is believed to have around
35,000 uh terrorists uh at best estimate
7 to
8,000 if you accept the Ida figures have
been killed that's not been confirmed at
all but if that is the case that's only
20% of the total that means that 80% of
herass terrorists have not been killed
yet uh again I'm staying with you Jen
for this I mean if your Israel and your
mission statement is to eradicate Hamas
the calls for ceasefire are going to
fall on deaf ears aren't they because
they're determined as we can hear from
all the rhetoric to finish the job as
they see
it yeah so let's be clear I mean I saw
the uh mark regab on before me uh the
propagandist for Israel that you had on
and uh first of all he thought it was
funny that my name was on the bombs I
don't think that the children that
they're murdering uh think it's funny uh
and the idea that they are not
indiscriminately killing civilians is
absurd so they dropped 2,000 pound bombs
in residential areas America never
Dropped a Bomb larger than 500 PBS in
residential area in Iraq and we did
great damage in Iraq four times larger
the area is the size of Las Vegas and
they've dropped
29,000 bombs nearly half of which are
unguided missiles then they shoot three
hostages uh dead without even checking
when they had a white flag and no shirt
on at all and if those three hostages
were Palestinians instead of Israelis no
one would have even noticed cuz now at
this point one more devastating fact
Hamas and what the did on October 7th
was terrible and they killed 846
civilians the rest Were Soldiers now
Israel has even if you take the IDF
numbers of saying that there's they K of
the 19,000 they killed is 5,000 they
claim is Hamas it's an absurd number a
total and utter lie not backed up by any
evidence but even if you accepted it
that means Israel has now killed 16
times as many civilians as the terrorist
group Hamas so what does that make is
should Israel leave Hamas 80% intact is
that good for anybody so no so now we
get to the absurdity of what Israel says
we are going to stay there until all of
Hamas is uh Gone how how do we know if
they're all gone how do we know if
they've surrendered how do we know if
the Palestinians have turned on Hamas
these these are all impossible standards
meant to eradicate uh Gaza entirely and
in fact they've almost done it already
90% of the people in Gaza are home
homeless we're picking out the body
parts of family members every single day
in Gaza it is one of and now that even
the New York Times and every Human
Rights group acknowledges this is one of
the worst massacres the biggest war
crimes committed in our lifetimes
America in 20 years in Afghanistan did
not kill as many civilians isra has
killed two months but should they leave
so now let me give you an answer let me
give you a productive way to do this how
to drive Hamas out you make a peace deal
with the Palestinian Authority that buys
them the credibil ability to be able to
say to the Palestinian people we have
delivered a state for you the thing that
we have been looking for our entire
lives and now because we have delivered
that for you we are going to run Gaza
that can drive Hamas out in a way that
is organic and driven by the
Palestinians themselves if you just try
to murder as many civilians as possible
in Gaza that is not an answer for
actually getting Hamas and by the way
the bombs have shown that they do not
affect the tunnels so all they're doing
is killing civilians let me bring in m
YF you're the son of the one of the
Hamas co-founders of course and
renounced that back in the the '90s you
believe uh that uh Israel should finish
the job they should eradicate
Hamas well absolutely because all the
calling for a ceas fire is calling for
surrender they want Israel to surrender
to the terrorist Savages and sit down at
the table and negotiate with them and
this is absolutely rejected
is there any deal to ever be done with
Hamas you know Hamas very well obviously
through your father is there any deal to
be done with a group like this
now there is no deal with the devil
there is no deal with Hamas as long as
they pose a threat uh against children
against civilians and destabilize
Security in the entire region if you if
they get away with their crime and their
crime is not just any crime it's a
genocide if they get away with their
crime what will they do tomorrow they
have to be punished and they have to be
held accountable all the calling for
sees fire those are the people who want
to give a Lifeline to Hamas and this is
not
acceptable masab you tweeted on Friday
uh something that many people found in
cury you said never trust anyone who
identifies as a Muslim they may be may
appear as a harmless sheep when they are
alone but when they're in a pack they
will begin to show their tusks I have
zero respect for any individual who
identifies as a Muslim and I may
consider the use of force when it comes
to islamist what did you mean by that
many people say well why would you say
that about you know over a billion
people well I don't care how many there
are any person who put the religious
identity above the highest interest of
human ity I have no respect for this
people the majority of the mus Muslim
people identified with Hamas supported
Hamas show me how many Muslims out there
who condemned Hamas genocide why because
is it because Jewish
blood this is what I meant that the
Muslims as long as they give Hamas cover
I have no respect for them as long as
identify as Muslims I have no respect
for them
but I've interviewed a number of Muslims
on this show who do not support Hamas
and have renounced him Jen himself came
on the show before and immediately
denounced what her masteral with I am
dealing with a majority of Muslim
countries
governments an entire nation don't tell
me about an individual here or or there
we're talking about a majority of Muslim
talk I'm only saying that because who
fail to take their moral resp
responsibility to take their moral
responsibility because it's Jewish
people I understand but you did say
literally every Muslim you said don't TR
trust anyone who identifies as a Muslim
that's all of them and what I'm saying
to you is I've interviewed many Muslims
on the show who are not extremists who
do not support what Hamas did who
believe what they did was a terrorist
they still need but they still have the
need for a religious identity which is a
false
identity individuality is something else
freedom is something else a person who
know who they are they are above all
national and religious identities there
is no need to pose as a Muslim in a
critical time in the human history this
is the time to take moreal
responsibility what's the point of of
identifying as a Muslim while people
threatening to
erase uh an entire Jewish community this
is not acceptable this is why I want the
Muslim to stand and be clear up to this
point I haven't seen I haven't seen the
Muslims taking a moral stand a a firm
stand against Hamas you know why because
they are Muslims because they are
Muslims against the Jewish people and
this is where I want the to push the
Muslims to the point where they need to
stand firmly and say it does matter if
they are Jewish or Christians a genocide
is a genocide and is rejected Hamas is
rejected I want to see this clearly then
after that I will have respect for the
majority of the Muslim people as long as
they fail their moral responsibility I
have no respect for them okay um you
made your point very firmly that me
bringing abam AB look a lot of emotions
run very high with this understandably a
lot of people have been killed on both
sides sides it's a horrific situation
you were in Israel on October the 7th
you've been back since you've spoken to
IDF soldiers you've been to the kutes
that were attacked you I think one of
your daughter's friends was killed I
mean you have it's personal for you you
know your your father survived the
Holocaust um what do you feel about all
this I feel sad to be honest I feel sad
but I want to tell you something I came
to
Israel few days before
the atmosphere was very pic my my son is
musician he's writing songs by the way
he write a song about the world that he
call it stoer I say why stoer I said
because for me everything sto in the
seventh of
October and then I woke up and Saturday
morning my friend called me say you
don't believe it 23 people was murdered
by the by the Hamas I said oh and he
started to watch a television the there
after uh my wife decided that we will
took our daughter Romy because she was
working in the in the television and you
know I don't know if you know I think
also you got all the videos horrible
videos she didn't want to see it on the
way back my daughter start to cry I say
why I say we found the LIE our friend he
was murdered in the in this party the
way party for peace party for peace not
only by the Jewish
people so this how I exposed to this
situation but I will tell
you it's a traged it's a it's a tragedy
all of this area is tragedy I'm not a
politician I'm a football guy but I live
in this area I have a lot of Muslim
friends I have a lot and I want one
thing to say two things first what would
you do what England would do if this
massacre happened in England what they
would do what you would do they would be
silence and not just this what do you
would do if the people that did it said
publicly we will do it again and we will
do it again and they show the videos by
the way all the videos was published by
them was videos by them even the Nazis
was hiding what they do what do you do
of course you need to prevent the second
time but are you comfortable Aram with
the scale of the response by Israel do
you feel comfortable now a lot of people
are feeling increasingly uncomfortable
and when you see three hostages being
killed you see women being killed
outside churches the pope calling it
terrorism the president of the United
States saying it's it's indiscriminate
bombing and so on do you feel
comfortable about this do you think that
Israel should just carry on or do you
think they should have a pause I'm not a
general of all things I think one thing
everybody know this Hamas don't need to
be in this area if the Hamas is not here
if the hostage will release by the way
which hostage is 10 months years old
four years old 85 years old your people
that was in the party it's not the
soldiers they didn't fight it's un I
never I don't remember in the history
hostages like this they need to release
them immediately they need to put the
weapon down one thing for sure I can say
to you Pi if they would put their weapon
down if they release the hostages and
they put all their efforts instead to
build tunnels instead to make missiles
to the to the I should say to the
quality of the people Gaza can be
paradise I can assure you to this for
sure do do you think Israel should
continue fighting until they get rid of
Hamas completely or that could mean many
many months if not years at the rate
they're going no I don't know people say
six weeks I don't know I think this is
need to be the target of the Free World
and Israel to get rid of the Kamas
because the Kamas I'm one of the that
believe them not believe that the number
they said we want to kill again we want
yeah they did there's no question of
that so you need to get rid of the Hamas
you need to get rid how to do it how to
do it I'm a football coach I'm not about
the day after the war what do you think
the future looks like here how do we get
to peace I will tell you exactly not
exactly I will tell you my opinion first
I have a lot of Muslim friends I have a
mus by the way I have a friends in
Gaza my wife even did a program about
family from Gaza I have a friends all
the Muslim the world they condemn what's
happened they don't like it I don't
agree with this guy I agree with him
that the Kamas is the devil but not all
the Muslims are like this they didn't
like what they do I think I think the
people in Gaza deserve other government
they deserve other leaders they need the
leaders that who should that be they
need to Le I don't know they need a
leader that they from them leader that
they take care of the quality of life
they need a leaders that will lead them
to the to this they need a leaders that
their target is not to hate their target
is to build something their target is to
do something not to hate others this
deserve one thing for sure you you know
the song of M the speech I Have a Dream
I also have a dream I have a dream that
it will happen I would tell you
something the leader that admire more
than more than anybody I think is the
number one leader on the 20th centur is
Anar sadad anas Sadat was a guy that was
the worst enemy of Israel in 25 years
four Wars one of them he started it yes
they killed each other many people died
many people got injured and this guy
came decided to come to Israel to the
Parliament and say I know I want a peace
and I will tell you something in these
days to say I'm going to Israel it's
more than belad will come to America you
know and he came and what's happened
this since then 50 years nobody died
it's a cold peace I want the peace will
be better nobody died I'm expect that
this leaders these leaders now in the
agent and I agree with the son of the
father will take responsibility and they
said let's make Gaza Paradise you know
that I I try to do a project of football
pites on the borders and I will do it by
the way PES Israel is playing
Palestinians yeah p and the people will
come to p i I try to do this project I
still believe in this but I expect this
leader maybe it's Muhammad bin Salman
maybe others I expect the leaders sit
together and say instead to give them
money for tunnels why they need the ters
why didn't make money to the quality of
the people like an Sadat came to Israel
very brave men I expect them to do this
and I will tell you I will tell you one
thing I've got to I've got to go
actually I think you're right I will put
all the leaders together that want peace
even from Iran even everybody that want
peace and want to make a Gaza parad they
can make it and you know how it started
when Anar Sadat called to water concrete
and say to him I'm ready to come to
Israel so maybe they will call you pe
and they say let's make peace let's make
Gaza and let's stop the intention to
killing other people because I agree
with Mark the Israel never have
intention to kill other people AB go
leave it there fascinating to talk to
you and great to see you thank you very
much indeed and to my two other guests I
really appreciate it uh U Jake I can see
you wanted to jump in we will come back
to this you're a powerful voice and I
will come back to you about this I've
just run out of time tonight but thank
you all very 9,000 dead children in Gaza
9,000 dead horr children it's acts of
terrorism I will get you back on again
soon and we'll talk about it again I
promise you that thank you all very much
for joining
me